foreign
accused of killing four University of
Idaho students has agreed to be
extradited from Pennsylvania to Idaho to
face murder charges Brian coveberger
made his first court appearance
yesterday the hearing came as police
released video of coburger getting
pulled over for allegedly speeding in
Indiana two weeks before his arrest
Tanya Backus is in Moscow Idaho Dania
good morning
good morning Adriana officials now have
nine days to bring Brian coburger here
to Idaho and just last night a judge in
the state issued a gag order blocking
law enforcement and attorneys from
discussing the case
wearing a red jumpsuit and Shackled with
armed guards suspect Ryan coburger
appeared stoic and calm as he walked
into a Pennsylvania courtroom Tuesday to
wave his extradition rights he's facing
four murder charges in Idaho for
allegedly stabbing to death Kaylee
Gonzalez Madison Mogan Zana kernodle and
Ethan Chapin in November once he's here
he is allowed by law to see an affidavit
explaining the evidence against him I
definitely believe that one of the main
reasons the defendant chose to wave
extradition and hurry his return back to
Idaho was the need to know what was in
those documents the 28 year old
criminology student was attending
Washington State University and lived
just 15 minutes from the crime scene
about a month after the murders coburger
went on a pre-planned road trip with his
father to their family's home in
Pennsylvania
new Dash and body cam footage released
by Indiana State Police show a trooper
pulling over co-berger during that trip
and this was not the only time they were
stopped
just minutes before a local sheriff's
deputy pulled the white Hyundai Elantra
over for allegedly following another
vehicle too closely
both times coburger received warnings
the two law enforcement agency said
there was no information available on a
suspect for the crime in Idaho at the
time of the traffic stops but a week
earlier Moscow police did release this
flyer asking for help finding the owner
of the same type of vehicle in
connection with the murderers sources
tell CBS news that law enforcement
surveilled the cross-country trip using
EZ Pass monitoring it's my sincere hope
that this marks a clear step in the
right direction of effectuating Justice
CBS News has learned authorities linked
DNA at the crime scene to coburger
thanks to familial DNA found in An
ancestry database if convicted co-burger
faces life in prison and possibly the
death penalty Nate
Tanya thank you